president biden is claiming a major
victory after making a compromise deal
on infrastructure with senators from
both parties but it only includes a
portion of the president's original
infrastructure plan
as ed o'keefe reports both sides still
have problems with the deal
a true bipartisan effort president biden
on a victory lap after striking a
bipartisan infrastructure deal
for a 579 billion dollar plan that would
invest in things like transportation
water projects and broadband internet
congress would pay for it in part by
boosting the irs's budget to go after
tax cheats
diverting billions in unused covert
relief funds and by selling some of the
nation's
strategic oil reserve but not everyone
is celebrating poultry
pathetic it has to be
combined with a second much more
robust adequate package
that second package is a significantly
larger more
expensive plan that includes so-called
human infrastructure
like child care green energy projects
and social programs
and has no republican support democrats
would have to pass that bill through
reconciliation
a process that only requires a simple
majority vote
there won't be an infrastructure bill
unless we have a reconciliation bill if
only one comes to me
i'm not if this is the only thing that
comes to me i'm not signing it it almost
makes your head span
an expression of bipartisanship and then
an ultimatum on behalf of your left-wing
base
but the president said he's confident
more republicans and democrats will sign
on to the bipartisan proposal what is it
about the conversations you've had
recently with republicans and give them
so much hope
i trust them when they say this is a
deal we'll stick to the deal
in another show of bipartisanship
lawmakers who've been working on a
long-awaited bill on police reform say
they've gotten agreement in principle
and we'll share other details in the
coming weeks meanwhile this morning vice
president kamala harris
is on her way to the u.s mexico border
for the first time
since being tapped by the president to
lead the response to
the illegal immigration crisis she along
with the homeland security secretary
alejandro mayorkas
will visit a customs and border
protection facility near el paso
and meet with local advocates anthony ed
o'keefe thank you ed